[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATALIE PIUCCO: Hi, everyone.
My name's Natalie, and we are
here in the G Suite demo booth.
And I'm joined here
by Rickard who's
from GANT, a customer who had an
amazing digital transformation
with G Suite.
Welcome.
RICKARD SODERBERG: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Tell us
a little bit about GANT
and how you opened up a
new store with G Suite
in three months.
Amazing.
RICKARD SODERBERG: So
GANT is a fashion brand.
We have our headquarters
in Stockholm today.
We're an old company--
was actually born in
USA from the beginning.
One of the things that we
did is we brought the button
down shirt to the market as
you can see all over here.
NATALIE PIUCCO: That's amazing.
Fun fact.
RICKARD SODERBERG: Yeah.
So a couple of years
ago, we had a challenge
where we had to open up
a new store on Regent
Street in London and we had to
do it in a record amount time.
So what usually takes one year,
we had to do in three months.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Oh, my goodness.
So you needed to work fast.
RICKARD SODERBERG:
We had to work fast.
NATALIE PIUCCO: So we've
actually got Whitney here,
as well, who's going to
take us through a demo.
Is that right?
RICKARD SODERBERG:
That is correct.
WHITNEY: Here we
have a cool video
of the London store actually
being built out by the team.
And as they were
planning, they had a lot
of documents going around.
They needed to be able to get
everyone on the same page,
working on the same document,
moving quickly together.
And so they used to send
file versions back and forth
all the time and it really
slowed down the process.
So they switched to Google Docs.
And using Google
Docs, they were all
able to work together on
the same document in all
of the different teams
across their locations.
And they were able to comment
each other in to assign tasks,
get inputs from team members
across all different locations,
and able to just really move
quickly together because they
were all running in
that same document.
And we're going to move now
from our London store team
to the Stockholm
headquarters team.
NATALIE PIUCCO: OK.
So now you're going
to show us what
the Stockholm team is doing
for inventory planning, right?
WHITNEY: Yes, exactly.
So we've just moved into
the Stockholm headquarters
where the team was also
working really hard to prepare
for the London store opening.
And they were focused
mostly on planning
all of the inventory
that was going
to be needed for the new store.
And so, in order
to do that, they
needed everyone working
on the same spreadsheet,
planning what was going on,
planning where the clothes were
coming from, how much we needed
of each item, things like that.
And the same way with
Docs, that they were all
able to collaborate live
on that one document,
they were able to
do the same thing
on the spreadsheet, which
helped them move really quickly,
as well.
And they also used
a feature called
Sheets Explore, which allows
people to ask questions
about their data
in natural language
so they can get insights
from their data,
like what's the average
price per quantity,
and things like that.
And, that way,
they're able to get
all of the information they
need to plan really effectively.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Through
actually asking through voice
those types of questions.
It's awesome because
a lot of people--
businesses don't
necessarily know
how to write SQL
or complex queries.
The Sheets Explore tool
is amazing for that.
WHITNEY: Yeah.
No longer do we have the
headaches of creating
all the pivot tables by hand.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Yes.
Amazing.
WHITNEY: But
rather, you can just
go in and get those insights
from your data right away.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Great.
OK.
Now we're going to imagine
we're in another country, right?
WHITNEY: Yes.
We've made it to Portugal
where the GANT manufacturing
facility is located.
NATALIE PIUCCO: A
quick trip to Portugal.
WHITNEY: Quick trip.
And so the team here
was working really hard
to create all of the
clothing that was going
to be needed for the store.
And so they were hard at
work in the manufacturing
facility really to make
the best items they could.
But they needed to get
approvals from the London
and the Stockholm teams
who were doing the designs,
and wanted to make sure it was
the quality they were looking
for, and things like that.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Sure.
And sometimes those
decisions just
need to be made
face-to-face, don't they?
WHITNEY: Yeah, exactly.
And so the GANT team used to
fly people to the manufacturing
facilities to check
out the clothing,
make sure it all looked good.
But now, they've really
switched to using
Meet, which is G Suite's
video conferencing solution.
And using Meet, they're able to
get everyone in the same room
virtually so they can
still see the look
and the feel of the clothing.
And so now, I'm actually
going to have the opportunity
to show you how
they would do that.
So we're already hooked in to
this meeting on our computer.
And I'm going to show you how
the team in the manufacturing
facility is able to join with
one click from the phone.
And then they-- actual
walk around with the phone
and join the meeting and be
able to see the clothing,
get a feel for it,
and this way, get
all of the approvals they
need for the clothing.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Amazing.
So you get the feeling that
you're actually in Porto,
although you're in
Stockholm. or London.
WHITNEY: Yes.
NATALIE PIUCCO: That's amazing.
Well, thank you so much
for this walk around.
This has definitely been one of
the most interactive sessions
and demonstrations.
Thanks, Whitney.
WHITNEY: No problem.
NATALIE PIUCCO: And
Rickard, also, I guess.
The G Suite
technology is amazing,
but I'm assuming this just
meant so much for your customers
to be able to move from
producing a store in one
year to three months.
RICKARD SODERBERG: It did.
It was a record time, and we
ended up with happy customers,
definitely.
NATALIE PIUCCO: I'd
imagine you did.
Thank you so much, both--
WHITNEY: Thank you.
NATALIE PIUCCO:
--for joining us.
WHITNEY: Really appreciate it.
NATALIE PIUCCO: Yeah.
Thanks.
[MUSIC PLAYING]